up to five minutes to talk about
whatever is on your mind yeah I mean I
do a lot on my mind but I really need to
hear
I think people need to hear that we need
to be kind to each other we need to be
more thoughtful of each other we need to
stop fighting so much and come together
and find solutions to our problems and
we need to engage with people that think
differently than us because that's how
that's going to happen that's the only
way that's going to happen and I think
that it I just hope it happens soon
because I'm tired of hearing horrible
things on the news on our way here we
had a very interesting plane ride we had
a conversation with a Marine Reserve
reservists who was coming out here for
additional stuff and he's also a New
York City police officer a great time
with that good conversation main thing
was that he's all about country he's all
about one nation under God and I believe
that I feel that it's a necessity for
each one of us to be together even
though we're all different we need to
establish the fact that we are here for
each other that we love one God and that
everybody can get along no matter what
color no matter what race no matter what
creed
we must friend over here would be the
perfect example he's blind and a lot of
people don't seem to pay attention to
that we can be a public and you will see
adults children and just running shoving
and not being attention or anything it
wouldn't mean a lot to me if people
little more attention to their
surroundings and if people like they
shouldn't be running into people really
like what if that person can't see or
what if they're in a wheelchair and you
shove them and they can't really stop
themselves or anything I'd have to say
that would be important to me having
people pay attention to their
surroundings more and being aware of
what other people are like just grateful
I've had two heart attacks had cancer
came back and eight weeks of radiation
cleared it up some cancer free again
just glad to be on one beautiful day
just warning signs of drugs you know
when people start to kind of break away
from you you know start watching out for
those warning signs you know and they
they disappear you know with no reasons
no explanations you know and and then
you start to get a little codependent on
that you know what am I doing wrong
it's not you you know it's them you know
and you got to keep that in mind when
you're in those kind of relationships
you know so do the best you can
and really it's hard for your heart not
to be broken especially in those kind of
situations because of your trying so
hard to be such a good person and then
to be so supportive and everything else
but then
a lot of times they're just beyond that
health and they really don't love it
I kind of feel like I'm ran
I guess that's really all I have to say
about that thanks for watching another
episode if you haven't already it would
mean a lot if you subscribe to my
channel like this video share it a
couple of sets of friends and help
support my project thank you
[Music]